GUN TO ALEC BALDWIN.
WHY HE WAS FIRED FROM A PRIOR
MOVIE.
LET'S GO OUTFRONT.
AND GOOD EVENING.
I'M ERIN BURNETT.
OUTFRONT TONIGHT, THE BREAKING
NEWS.
FACEBOOK CEO MARK ZUCKERBERG ON
THE DEFENSE.
MOMENTS AGO, ZUCKERBERG ON AN
EARNINGS CONFERENCE CALL
SPEAKING TO INVESTORS, ADDRESSED
THE THOUSANDS OF PAGES OF LEAKED
INTERNAL DOCUMENTS WHICH PAINT A
DAMNING PICTURE OF THE COMPANY'S
PROBLEMS.
FROM PROMOTING EXTREMISM TO
HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND HERE'S
WHAT HE JUST SAID ON THE CALL.
I AM QUOTING MARK ZUCKERBERG.
GOOD-FAITH CRITICISM HELPING US
GET BETTER BUT MY VIEW IS THAT
WE ARE SEEING A COORDINATED
EFFORT TO SELECTIVELY USE LEAKED
DOCUMENTS TO PAINT A FALSE
PICTURE OF OUR COMPANY.
THE LEAKED DOCUMENTS HE IS
TALKING ABOUT ARE KNOWN AS THE
FACEBOOK PAPERS.
AND THEY WERE ORIGINALLY LEAKED
BY WHISTLE-BLOWER FRANCES
HAUGEN.
THEY OFFER A DISTURBING LOOK
INSIDE THE SOCIAL MEDIA GIANT
BECAUSE AMONG THE ALLEGATIONS OF
HAUGEN'S IS THAT FACEBOOK
STRUGGLED TO REGULATE HATE
SPEECH AND MISINFORMATION, WHICH
EVENTUALLY HELPED SPUR THE
DEADLY INSURRECTION ON JANUARY
6th WERE DONE IN PART BECAUSE
THEY PROFITED FROM ALL THAT
STUFF BEING THERE.
THE PLATFORM, ALSO, OF COURSE,
NOW, ALLEGEDLY THEY ARE SEEING
MORE USE BY HUMAN TRAFFICKERS.
ACCORDING TO REPORTS, ZUCKERBERG
NOW CLAIMS HE IS RETOOLING THE
COMPANY AWAY FROM OLDER USERS
SAYING IT WILL MAKE QUOTE
SERVING YOUNG ADULTS OUR NORTH
STAR.
LET ME JUST POINT THE OBVIOUS
HERE.
THAT WHEN YOU ARE IN A COMPANY
MAKING BILLIONS AND BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AND YOU SAY ALL THE
SUDDEN, WE ARE GOING TO AGE CUT
OFF AND NOT DO ANYTHING WITH
THOSE PEOPLE, THAT IS LIKE A
BUSINESS MODEL IMPLOSION.
RIGHT?
TALK ABOUT LOSING MONEY.
ALL RIGHT.
FACEBOOK IS NOW TRYING TO PUT
THE GENIE BACK INTO THE BOTTLE
BUT THE DAMAGE IS DONE.
THE LIES ABOUT THE LEK ELECTION
HAVE TAKEN ON A LIFE OF THEIR
OWN.
AND TODAY, HAUGEN WARNING OF
ANOTHER JANUARY 6th LIKE EVENT,
UNLESS FACEBOOK TAKES MUCH MORE
DRASTIC STEPS.
>> I HAVE NO DOUBT THAT THE LIKE
THE EVENTS WE ARE SEEING AROUND
THE WORLD THINGS LIKE MYANMAR
AND ETHIOPIA, THOSE ARE THE
OPENING CHAPTERS SO IF FACEBOOK
COMES BACK AND SAYS ONLY A TINY
SLIVER OF CONTENT ON OUR
PLATFORM IS HATE OR EVENLY A
TINY SLIVER VIOLENCE, I DON'T
KNOW IF I TRUST THOSE NUMBERS
BUT, TWO, IT GETS
HYPERCONCENTRATED IN, YOU KNOW,
5% OF THE POPULATION.
AND YOU ONLY NEED 3% OF THE
POPULATION ON THE STREETS TO
HAVE A REVOLUTION.
>>> SHE WARNS OF A REVOLUTION
AND WHEN YOU HEAR ZUCKERBERG'S
FULL-THROATED DEFENSE OF THE
COMPANY, IT DOESN'T APPEAR HE IS
WILLING TO MAKE THAT MANY
CHANGES BECAUSE, ACCORDING TO
HAUGEN, THERE IS ONLY ONE THING
THAT MATTERS TO ZUCKERBERG AND
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE.
>> THE THING I SAW AT FACEBOOK
OVER AND OVER AGAIN WAS THERE
WERE CONFLICTS OF INTEREST
BETWEEN WHAT WAS GOOD FOR THE
PUBLIC AND WHAT WAS GOOD FOR
FACEBOOK.
AND FACEBOOK, OVER AND OVER
AGAIN, CHOSE TO OPTIMIZE FOR ITS
OWN INTERESTS, LIKE MAKING MORE
MONEY.
>> SO, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THAT
HISTORY, JUST THINK ABOUT THIS,
JUST PUT SOME NUMBERS OUT THERE.
IF THEY ARE GOING TO FOCUS ON
YOUNG PEOPLE.
RIGHT NOW, 3% OF THEIR USERS ARE
THE AGES OF 13 AND 17.
18% ARE BETWEEN 35 AND 44 WHICH
YOU ARE GETTING UP THERE INTO
THE OLD RANGE, RIGHT?
I MEAN, YOU ARE THOUGH THROWING
AWAY HUGE PARTS YOU HAVE YOUR
BUSINESS.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE THAT EASY.
ALEX MARQUARDT IS OUTFRONT.
SO, ALEX, WHAT ELSE DO THESE
FACEBOOK PAPERS SHOW ABOUT THE
COMPANY'S ROLE IN JANUARY 6th?
>> WELL, ERIN, THESE THOUSANDS
AND THOUSANDS OF -- OF PAGES
THAT WERE LEAKED BY THIS
FACEBOOK WHISTLE-BLOWER SHOW THE
EMPLOYEES OF FACEBOOK WERE WELL
AWARE THE PLATFORM THEY WORK FOR
WAS HELPING FUEL HATE AND THE
POTENTIAL FOR POLITICAL
VIOLENCE, AS WELL AS
MISINFORMATION AND NOT JUST
AROUND THE ELECTION LAST
NOVEMBER AND THE VIOLENT
INSURRECTION IN JANUARY THAT
FOLLOWED BUT WELL BEFORE THAT.
ERIN, AFTER JANUARY 6th, WE DID
HEAR FROM CHERYL SANDBERG, THE
COO OF FACEBOOK, AND SHE SAID AT
THE TIME THAT SHE WAS AWARE THAT
SOME OF THIS VIOLENCE HAD BEEN
ORGANIZED ONLINE BUT THAT IT WAS
LARGELY ON PLATFORMS THAT WERE
LESS REGULATED, THAT HAD FEWER
STANDARDS AND LESS OF AN ABILITY
TO STOP HATE THAN FACEBOOK.
BUT NOW, WHAT WE ARE SEEING FROM
THESE FACEBOOK EMPLOYEES IS THAT
THEY BELIEVE THAT FACEBOOK WAS
LARGELY UNPREPARED FOR WHAT WAS
TO COME.
AND THAT THEY REALLY DIDN'T TAKE
ANY SORT OF ACTION AGAINST THE
STOP THE STEAL MOVEMENT THAT
CAME ABOUT AFTER THE ELECTION
UNTIL IT TURNED VIOLENT.
ONE OF THE FACEBOOK EMPLOYEES
SAID THAT THE RESPONSE FROM THE
COMPANY HAD BEEN PIECEMEAL.
ESSENTIALLY, THAT THE APPROACH
THEY HAD TAKEN WAS WHACK A MOLE.
THEY WERE TAKING DOWN
INDIVIDUALS AND GROUPS AND
FAILING TO SEE THIS AS A MUCH
LARGER MOVEMENT AND SO WHEN
THESE EXECUTIVES STARTED
SPEAKING OUT INTERNALLY AND
EXTERNALLY, DEFENSIVELY, ABOUT
FACEBOOK AFTER JANUARY 6th, A
NUMBER OF FACEBOOK EMPLOYEES
ALSO RESPONDED.
I WANT TO READ YOU A QUOTE FROM
ONE OF THEM PUSHING BACK SAYING,
ALL DUE RESPECT, BUT HAVEN'T WE
HAD ENOUGH TIME TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO MANAGE DISCOURSE WITHOUT
ENABLING VIOLENCE?
WE HAVE BEEN FUELING THIS FIRE
FOR A LONG TIME, AND WE
SHOULDN'T BE SURPRISED IT'S NOW
OUT OF CONTROL.
ANOTHER, ERIN, WROTE HISTORY
WILL NOT JUDGE US KINDLY.
THIS IS, ARGUABLY, ERIN, THE
BIGGEST -- ONE OF THE BIGGEST,
IF NOT THE BIGGEST CRISIS
FACEBOOK HAS EVER FACED IN ITS
EXISTENCE.
>> >> I WANT TO GO NOW TO SENIOR
POLITICAL ANALYST, JOHN AVLON.
HE IS A FORMER FEDERAL
PROSECUTOR.
I MEAN, SORRY, AND FWORM FORMER
FEDERAL PROSECUTOR.
MANY THINGS BUT NOT A FORMER
PROSECUTOR.
OKAY.
THANKS TO BOTH OF YOU.
JOHN, I WANT TO, FIRST, MARK
ZUCKERBERG BEING DEFIANT TONIGHT
AND I JUST READ SOME OF WHAT HE
SAID BUT HE JUST SAID IT ON AN
EARNINGS CONFERENCE CALL.
WE WERE ABLE TO OBTAIN THE AUDIO
SO I THINK HEARING THE TONE
MATTERS.
HERE IS MARK ZUCKERBERG.
>> GOOD-FAITH CRITICISM HELPS US
GET BETTER.
BUT MY VIEW IS THAT WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IS A COORDINATED EFFORT
TO SELECTIVELY USE LEAKED
DOCUMENTS TO PAINT A FALSE
PICTURE OF OUR COMPANY.
THE REALITY IS THAT WE HAVE AN
OPEN CULTURE WHERE WE ENCOURAGE
DISCUSSION AND RESEARCH ABOUT
OUR WORK SO WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS
ON MANY COMPLEX ISSUES THAT ARE
NOT SPECIFIC TO JUST US.
>> SO -- SO, JOHN, I MEAN, YOU
KNOW, HE WAS OBVIOUSLY VERY
DEFENSIVE THERE.
WE ARE SEEING A COORDINATED
EFFORT TO SELECTIVELY LEAK
DOCUMENTS TO PAINT A FALSE
PICTURE OF THE COMPANY.
>> THE GOOD-FAITH CRITICISM IS
COMING FROM WITHIN HIS COMPANY.
AND THESE FILES ARE NOT SIMPLY
COMMENTS FROM FORMER EMPLOYEES.
IT'S INTERNAL RESEARCH.
INTERNAL DATA.
ALL LEADING TO A VERY CLEAR
CONCLUSION THAT ITS OWN
ALGORITHMS AND THE ECONOMIC
INCENTIVES CREATED BY THOSE ALG
I THI
ALGORITHMS IS ELEVATING THE MOST
NEGATIVE CONTENT AND COMMENTS IN
PEOPLE'S FEEDS.
THAT IS A HUGE PROBLEM NOT JUST
FOR FACEBOOK AND ITS EARNINGS
BUT FOR SOCIETY.
AND THAT'S THE ALGORITHM IS
SOMETHING WELL WITHIN HIS
CONTROL.
>> SO, JENNIFER, YOU KNOW, HERE
WE ARE.
I MEAN, THEY ARE FACING
OBVIOUSLY THE POSSIBILITY OF
MASSIVE LEGAL ACTION AS WELL,
RIGHT?
SO FRANCES HAUGEN, THE
WHISTLE-BLOWER, SHE SAYS WHAT
FACEBOOK DID DAY IN AND DAY OUT
WAS PUT WHAT WAS GOOD FOR
PROFITS OVER WHAT WAS GOOD FOR
THE PUBLIC, RIGHT?
THEY COULD HAVE PULLED SOME OF
THIS BACK AND THEY DID NOT.
HOW DO YOU PROVE THAT?
THE DOCUMENTS THAT WE HAVE, ARE
THOSE ENOUGH?
I MEAN, HOW DO YOU PROVE THAT
IN -- IN -- IN A COURT?
>> SO, THE PROBLEM, ERIN, IS
THAT COMPANIES LIKE FACEBOOK
HAVE A LOT OF PROTECTION FROM
SECTION 230 OF THE
COMMUNICATIONS DECENCY ACT.
YOU CAN'T JUST SUE THEM, AND WIN
BY SAYING, YOU KNOW, THEY HAVE A
PLATFORM THAT ALLOWS EXTREMISM.
THEY DIDN'T DO ENOUGH TO FIGHT
AGAINST THEIR -- THE CONTENT
THAT THEIR USERS WERE POSTING.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE SOME SORT OF
AFFIRMATIVE ACTION, INTENTIONAL
ACTION ON THEIR PART WHERE THEY
KNEW SOMETHING, AND THEY LIED
ABOUT IT.
SO THE WHISTLE-BLOWER HAS FILED
A COMPLAINT WITH THE SECURITIES
AND EXCHANGES COMMISSION.
IF SHE CAN PROVE AND IF THESE
DOCUMENTS PROVE AND TESTIMONY IS
THE S.E.C. CAN COLLECT PROVES
THAT FACEBOOK LIED IN ITS PUBLIC
FILINGS OR TO ITS INVESTORS
ABOUT INFORMATION THAT IT KNEW
THAT THEIR PLATFORM AND THEIR
PRODUCT WAS DANGEROUS, AND THAT
THEY LIE ABOUT THAT, THEN YOU
CAN POTENTIALLY HOLD THEM
RESPONSIBLE.
OTHERWISE, IT'S VERY, VERY
DIFFICULT JUST ON THE BASIS THEY
DID SOMETHING THAT WAS
DANGEROUS.
>> AND, JOHN, TODAY, YOU HAVE
HAUGEN WHO IS IN POSSESSION OF
ALL THESE DOCUMENTS ADAMANT THAT
IF THEY DON'T MAKE CHANGES, THAT
SHE BELIEVES MORE EVENTS LIKE
JANUARY 6th WILL TAKE PLACE.
HOW SERIOUSLY SHOULD WE TAKE HER
WARNING?
>> INCREDIBLY SERIOUSLY.
BECAUSE, LOOK, I THINK IF YOU
LOOK AT THE WAY OUR COLLECTIVE
POLITICS HAVE GONE INSANE OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF MACROFACTORS
BUT ONE OF THE CLEAR DRIVERS
THAT HAS MADE YOUR -- YOUR SORT
OF RANDOM AUNTS AND UNCLES, ALL
THE SUDDEN, COME TO THE IT CAN
TABLE ARMED WITH CONSPIRACY
THEORIES AND ALTERNATIVE FACTS
IS THEIR FACEBOOK FEED.
AND I THINK EVERY CASE CAN BE
MADE THAT FACEBOOK HAS HIT SORT
OF A BIG-TOBACCO MOMENT WHERE
THEIR OWN INTERNAL RESEARCH AND
DATA SHOWS THEY KNEW THIS
ALGORITHM WAS A PROBLEM AND
WHILE SECTION 230 SHOULD PROTECT
PLATFORMS FROM ANYTHING SOME
RANDOM PERSON MIGHT POST ON
THEIR SITE TO A LARGE EXTENT.
THE ALGORITHMS ARE THE DECISIONS
OF THE OWN COMPANIES, AND BY
OPTIMIZING FOR ENGAGEMENT, THEY
EN
ENDED UP REWARDING THE MOST
NEGATIVE AND EXTREME CONTENT AND
THAT HAS HELPED POLITICAL
EXTREMISM WHICH HAS DISFIGURED
OUR DEMOCRACY.
SOMETIMES WITH DEADLY RESULTS.
>> JENNIFER, HERE IS THE THING.
EVEN BEFORE THIS -- THIS RECENT
SITUATION WITH THE ELECTION,
RIGHT, AND ITS AFTERMATH, THERE
WERE MURDERS COMMITTED ON
FACEBOOK LIVE.
HORRIFIC THINGS HAPPENING FOR
YEARS THEY WERE STRUGGLING TO
DEAL WITH AND I SPOKE EARLIER
THIS MONTH TO ANDY PARKER.
YOU WILL KNOW HIM BECAUSE HIS
DAUGHTER ALLISON WAS SHOT AND
KILLED ON LIVE TELEVISION WHILE
SHE WAS DOING HER JOB AND FOR
YEARS, HE HAS BEEN FIGHTING WITH
FACEBOOK TO TAKE DOWN VIDEOS OF
HER MURDER.
AND HERE'S WHAT HE TOLD ME
FACEBOOK SAID WHEN IT WAS
COMMITTED TO REMOVING THOSE
VIDEOS.
MARK ZUCKERBERG THEN DENIED
PUSHING EXTREME OR HATEFUL
CONTENT FOR PROFIT.
HERE'S WHAT HER DAD SAID.
>> HE'S A LIAR.
IT'S THE SAME NONSENSE AND THE
SAME BS THAT I'VE BEEN HEARING
FOR FIVE YEARS.
OH, YEAH, WE DO.
WE -- YOU KNOW, THIS IS NOT
ALLOWED ON OUR -- ON OUR
PLATFORMS AND WE ARE GOING TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN AND YADA-YADA
AND THAT'S ALL YOU GOT IS LIP
SERVICE AND UNTIL THESE
COMPANIES -- FACEBOOK,
YOUTUBE -- UNTIL THEY ARE FORCED
IN A COURT, YOU KNOW, THROUGH
THE REMOVAL OF THEIR PROTECTION
FROM LIABILITY, THEY ARE GOING
TO JUST KEEP DOING THE SAME
THING.
>> JENNIFER, DOES HE HAVE A
POINT?
>> WELL, HE'S EXACTLY RIGHT IN
WHAT HE SAID, WHICH IS UNTIL
THEIR PROTECTION IS REMOVED,
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE IN COURT,
THOUGH.
IT'S GOING TO BE IN CONGRESS.
I MEAN, CONGRESS CAN AMEND OR
ELIMINATE THE PROTECTION THAT
THEY HAVE UNDER SECTION 230 BUT
WITH THAT PROTECTION, IT'S VERY,
VERY HARD TO SUE THEM FOR